so you've collected some full classified
sets some decent weapons and now you're
to optimize them to get the best out of
your build great but before you jump in
and spend all the division tech that
you've been saving up over the last few
weeks or months there's a few things you
should be aware of just sooo that you
can get the most bang for your buck to
fully understand what's being covered
we'll start by quickly going over gear
score in the early game from level 1 to
30 that's your character level that's
displayed and as your level increases
the level of gear and weapons that drop
increases too once you hit level 30 the
number displayed changes over to gear
score at the same time weapons and gear
that start to drop a now represented by
gear score as well the gear score
numbers are broken down into five tiers
these five tiers correspond to the world
tiers so will Tier one has 163 to 181
gear score items all the way out to
world tier 5 which has 256 to 286 or 293
for classified items excluding the
holster witches 295 and this is why most
will say just to rush up to world tier 5
as soon as you hit level 30
because gear found on the lower tiers
very quickly becomes obsolete as you
move through the world tiers the gear
score of an item reflects the quality of
the gear so in will tier 5 the gear
score of a standard item can range from
256 to 286 256 being the lower quality
and 286 being the maximum value that
piece of gear can be note gear score
does not take into account the talents
or stats that are on the weapon or gear
this and this is the reason to ignore
gear score at first and instead look at
the stats and talents and then worry
about whether it's worth the currency to
further optimize so a piece with 256
gear score but god roll talents will
always be more valuable than a piece
with higher gear score and rubbish
talents finally this may be obvious to a
lot of you but I've seen it asked a lot
if an item drops on a specific world
tier they can only ever have a gear
score within the range of that world
tier again I'll show this little chart
so a weapon that drops on world tier 4
can only be optimized to a maximum gear
score of 255 you cannot continue to
optimize it into the will tier 5 gear
score range
unless you're absolutely swimming in
division tic there's a few things you
can look at before optimizing your
builds recalibrate your gear before
optimizing if there are some stats to be
recalibrated do this before you start
optimizing optimizing a piece of gear
and then recalibrating a stat will be
undoing some of the optimization so for
example if you have a chest piece with
the rolls you're after that the main
stat is in the wrong area recalibrate
this before heading to the optimization
station or you'll be spending even more
division tick reoptimize in it
recalibrating isn't just useful to
change stats before optimization it can
also save you a bunch of diptych if you
bring your stats as close to the maximum
as possible before optimizing for
example if you have a classified hostel
with 1280 firearms 1380 stamina and
1,400 electronics and you've already
rolled the major stat into the state of
your choosing this piece is already
pretty close to being maxed apart from
the firearms but since you have an extra
slot you can recalibrate because it's a
classified piece if you recalibrated
firearms so that it was closer to the
maximum level it would mean that you're
spending even less on optimizing which
is considerably more expensive than
recalibrating the cost of using the
optimization station is two hundred and
fifty thousand credits and fifty
division tick per roll and it can take
up to 19 rolls to get to the maximum
gear score on an item costing a total of
four million seven hundred fifty
thousand credits and nine hundred and
fifty division tick now imagine that
over a whole six piece build and that
doesn't include weapons this is
obviously a worst case scenario because
you're feeling unlikely to get a piece
with the minimum possible stats that's
worth keeping let alone a whole build
but it gives you an idea of the
associated costs and how you should be
pretty happy with a piece before you
think about optimizing credits are
pretty easy to come by but how do you
increase your dev tech income right now
the single best way is to make sure that
you do your weekly and daily assignments
if all you do is complete them every day
and finish the weeklies you can earn a
total of a thousand of tech per week if
you have multiple characters you can
earn even more as the materials are
shared so with four characters you can
earn up to four thousand you can also
find a lot more division tech playing
resistance activities in the West Side
Pier farming the darks
extracting caches and exotic caches can
give a decent amount to but the
assignments are by far the easiest and
most time efficient way the optimization
station could be found down in the
terminal and at Camp Clinton I like to
start with weapons first particularly
the ones I use over multiple builds
careful not to get carried away though
if it doesn't have the perfect talents
save the diptych next onto the gear the
best piste without a doubt is the
holster as this increases all three main
stats after that look at what stats need
increasing maybe you need a little more
firearms to unlock that whip and talent
or maybe you have a piece that's really
lagging behind the rest when you're
optimizing your gear you'll notice that
it's the main step that takes the
longest to increase to maximum and this
is part of the reason that it's
recommended that you recalibrate these
first if possible the attribute that you
should put the lowest priority on is
armor the difference from the minimum
possible armor rolls to the maximum is
about 5% and with the way that armor
currently works in the game this equates
to about one bullet worth of mitigation
in fact the only reason to continue
optimizing until everything is maxed is
because your OCD is and like to see
everything completed like me but for the
rest of you mere mortals here is the
order that I'd recommend when you start
optimizing a belt when on a division
tech budget of course there are
exceptions to this but it's a good
starting point the max gear school you
can get on weapons and non-classified
gear is 286 and unclassified gear is 293
excluding the holster which maxes out at
about 295 the gear school given to your
agent is the average of all of your gear
so if your build is made up with a six
piece classified set everything is fully
optimized you'll have a gear score of
291 when getting the most out of your
gear versus the cost of optimization it
isn't about maxing out every piece of
your build it's more about focusing what
you need to work on first and where
possible recalibrate your gear as high
as you can before optimizing division
tech may be easy to get these days but
with proper planning you can save
thousands meaning you can optimize more
faster I feel like I may have missed an
obvious tip or two on the subject so if
you notice anything I may not have
covered let everyone know in the
comments below otherwise I must thank
Trigger 739 from the MG and discord
channel for the
your suggestion it's a true in-game
topic worth talking about in an area
where people often misuse their precious
division tech anyway thank you for
watching and I'll catch you in the next
one
Cheers
[Music]